hey guys my name is jeff mcdonald today
is the second of December and you're
tuned into Kate's [ __ ] hallo master
chief collection is due to get yet
another patch which is yet again
supposed to fix that hole broken game
thing the update will address the game's
janky matchmaking system which is still
causing issues since the game's release
on November 11 developer 343 industries
wrote on the games website the team
continues development and testing of
upcoming content updates the next of
which will specifically make
improvements to the matchmaking system
and flow this particular update is on
track for delivery this week we will
provide more details on the exact ETA
included fixes and additional upcoming
content updates in the near future
destiny fans on sony consoles are all
set to be treated with exclusive content
that set to come out with the first
expansion the dark below it's just a
timed exclusive so those of you on xbox
will be able to grab the content
eventually post fall of 2015 the content
consists of one strike mission and a new
exotic weapon for the strike mission
called the undying mind you'll be
returning to the black garden to fight a
massive vex machine which looks like a
souped-up version of the existing Hydra
and Templar enemies as with the other
strikes it's a three-player mission that
can be played with friends or through
matchmaking the fancy exotic weapon is a
four barrel shotgun with a high fire
rate which should do the job when it
comes to blasting your foes to tiny
little pieces sony have made a big
announcement and we have absolutely no
idea what it is the trailer called Emma
gone is entirely in spanish and features
a man exploring the woods with a compass
and then finding a plant in a desert
I've actually no better way to explain
what on earth just happened the
narration includes 12 20 years
conquering worlds making choices and
living with the consequences of said
choices it's worth noting that Emma gone
backwards spells no
game and that Sony is just about to
celebrate 20 years of PlayStation
according to the video we'll find out
more on december five as for your
question of the day let me know what you
think is happening in the trailer and
what you're hoping it's going to be you
can have to gain slots and more stories
on things like the Dead Island 2 theta
and what to expect from the game awards
that is it for me today I'll have a
bunch more news tomorrow so I hope to
see them